herzlich willkommen zufolge 197 das faz
einen spruch podcast der wöchentlichen
podcast der faz für recht justiz und
politik heute am 9 februar
2022 mein name ist corinna budras ich
bin berlin korrespondent in der faz und
am anderen ende der leitung ist diesmal
wieder pia lorenz meyer aus köln ich bin
freie journalistin und
ja wir steigen gleich ein ohne große
vorrede in die themen denn es wird uns
corona natürlich in mannigfaltiger art
und weise mal wieder beschäftigen was
machen wir eigentlich ein cooler vorbei
ist da noch genug themen ja das werden
wir dann sehen aber es ginge auch
zweieinhalb jahre davor ja auch sagen es
war ziemlich munter aber diesmal müssen
uns einmal um den noch mal um die
verkürzung des genießen den status
kümmern der ja für viel wirbel sorgte
und auch dutts forderungen gegenüber
herrn wieder den leiter des rk ii und es
gab auch ein urteil dazu es gab ein
urteil und ein gutachten vom
wissenschaftlichen dienst des bundestags
das schauen wir uns an und dann gucken
wir uns natürlich so ein bisschen das
thema des tages an nämlich die
einrichtungs bezogen 11 licht was wird
daraus eigentlich die taz hat heute
morgen getitelt team scheiß drauf mehr
dazu später
es laufen wird einfach mal so stehen
dann haben wir noch was ganz anderes
nämlich den bgh zum berliner wettbüro
fall den du uns mal vorstellen wirst
liebe bier
und wir haben den bundesfinanzhof oder
den haben wir viel mehr nicht denn der
hat immer noch keine neue vize-chefin
der bayerische verwaltungsgerichtshof
hat vor wenigen tagen entschieden dass
anker nicht die neue vize-präsidentin
des bfh wird das wirst du uns ein
bisschen vorstellen aber es gibt so ein
bisschen politische verwirrung und auch
richtige handfesten streit um die neue
besetzung der spitzenposten an deutschen
bundesgerichten und das haben wir ein
bisschen freuen uns hergeschoben die
letzten monate aber jetzt dachten wir
jetzt eigentlich einmal guter zeitpunkt
um sie um euch darauf hinzuweisen dass
ich da eigentlich tut und wie politisch
so eine besetzung eigentlich ausfällt so
und dann haben wir noch ein paar
nachträge kleine klarstellung und das
gerechte urteil der woche das gar kein
urteil ist aber eine hübsche anekdote
das ist eine sehr hübsche anekdote ich
möchte weiterhin dafür plädieren dass
wir vielleicht das gerechte urteil
umbenennen in schöne dinge oder so also
auf jeden fall ilike very much eine sehr
hübsche geschichte aus der letzten er
schöne dinge aus dem gerichtssaal wobei
saal in diesem zusammenhang sehr sehr
weit zu verstehen ist also aber mehr
verraten wir nicht
so liebe pia dann beginnen wir jetzt mit
dem genesenen status und dem wirbel und
den rechtlichen unsicherheiten die sich
damit verbinden erzähl doch mal wie ist
da der stand der dinge
ganz kurz am 1 wir haben das schon ein
bisschen vorgestellt in der folge 193
vom 19 januar ist also alles noch gar
nicht so lange her mitte januar wurde
der genesenden status von einem tag auf
den anderen von sechs auf drei monate
verkürzt das gab ziemlichen wirbel und
zwar sowohl politisch als auch
verfassungsrechtlich warum noch mal
es gab eine änderung in der meine
lieblings verordnung cupid 19
schutzmaßnahmen ausnahmen verordnung der
bundesregierung die also ausnahmen von
den coup 19 schutzmaßnahmen definiert
insbesondere für gäste und genießen in
diesem fall für die gemessenen in dieser
verordnung der bundesregierung gab es
nämlich eine änderung nämlich einen
sogenannten eine sogenannte dynamische
verweisung also da wird jetzt für die
frage was ein genesenen nachweis ist auf
deutsch wann man eigentlich als genesen
gilt oder noch gilt das steht jetzt
nicht mehr in dieser verordnung drin
sondern das steht jetzt auf der seite
des robert koch instituts das heißt er
ist also einfach so ein verweis darauf
dass finden sie unter url des robert
koch instituts und während auf dieser
seite am 14 januar halt noch stand dass
man sechs monate nach der infektion als
genießen gilt und auch dass auch der
bundesrat noch so mitgeteilt hat hat
dann einen tag später still und leise
das rk ii das geändert und plötzlich
stand samstags auf der seite dass man
jetzt nur noch drei monate als genesen
gehen das jetzt hat man nicht so geil
weil man hat plötzlich aus dem
gesellschaftlichen leben rausgekickt ist
ja und übrigens um das noch mal deutlich
zu sagen das ist auch wirklich als
verkürzt sich die zeit dramatisch na
also denn dieser genesenen status von
dem profitiert man ja ohnehin auch erst
28 tage nachdem pcr test nach dem
positiven pc etwas das heißt man
verliert eigentlich auch schon monat und
dann
hat man zwei monate halli galli und dann
auf einmal
in einem boden tiefes loch wenn man das
mal so plastisch formulieren darf ich
glaube es hat wirklich ziemlich viele
und wir reden hier von tausenden von
menschen die das betroffen haben muss
potenziell millionen weil das sind ja
jetzt auch zehn millionen die wir schon
die schon genesen sind die also diesen
status hatten jedenfalls im lauf verlauf
der pandemie ist natürlich schon etliche
die auch schon weiter zurückliegen denn
lothar wieler der chef der srg hat er
festgestellt dass im moment die
infektions lage so dramatisch ist dass
wir jetzt zehn prozent aller
neuinfektionen haben in und zwar vom
gesamten zeitraum also wir haben über
eine strecke von 2 ja jetzt schon über
zehn millionen genesenen registriert und
allein zehn prozent stammt aus den
vergangenen wochen also das ist schon
eine ziemlich deutliche
änderung und wie gesagt also knapp zwei
jahre hat sich an diesen sechs monaten
eigentlich gar nichts getan die standen
ziemlich fest in der
einheit auch auf europäischer ebene
heißt na also in ganz europa hat man sie
oft auf die sechs monate geeinigt und
plötzlich sagt man in deutschland dann
und sagt nicht mann sondern sagt dass
lkw plötzlich schwupp sie nur noch drei
das war schon relativ blöd vor allem für
die betroffenen genau da haben wir das
hinbekommen im januar und jetzt gibt es
aber auch rechtliche von die rock für
diese schnappatmung
ich fürchte es wird niemand sagen so
schon zurecht budras und logan diesem
podcast form aber es hat uns quasi jetzt
wirklich tatsächlich recht gegeben der
wissenschaftliche dienst des bundestags
schon vor zwei wochen und in der
vergangenen woche auch noch das
verwaltungsgericht osnabrück also der
wissenschaftliche dienst des bundestags
hält gleich zwei dinge für kritisch
nämlich nicht erst die dynamische
verweisung auf das rk ii sondern der
bundestag sagt und beruft sich dabei
auch auf namhafte verfassungsrechtler
und verfassungsrecht drinnen die das
wohl schon im april 20 21 angemerkt
hatten in der öffentlichen anhörung des
gesundheitsausschusses
das ist schon echt schräg ist sowas
relevantes wie den genesenen status der
ebenso viele menschen betrifft
unmittelbar im alltag überhaupt per
rechtsverordnung
26 zu delegieren ja genau ja genau also
das ist ja so ein bisschen das was wir
auch angesprochen hatten die
wesentlichkeit der theorie des
bundesverfassungsgerichts wesentliches
muss der gesetzgeber selbst regeln und
da sagen eben die die wissenschaftlerin
vom bundestag wie naja das finden wir an
sich schon schräg dass das dann
dirigiert wird auf die bundesregierung
per verordnung und dann kommt eben noch
hinzu die dynamische verweisung auf die
internetseite des rk ii die ja ständig
geändert werden kann ohne dass das auch
nur kommuniziert werden müsste also
jetzt ganz kurz für den jura nerds da
hält der wissenschaftliche dienst sogar
mehrere aspekte für ziemlich schwierig
nämlich erstens dass verkündung sgw
angebot gesetze und verordnungen müssen
ja verkündet werden das ist aber kein
gesetz und keine verordnung das rk ii
muss überhaupt nichts verkünden deswegen
hat auch zwei tage gedauert bis das
irgendwer überhaupt mitbekommen hatte
dann könnte das eine unzulässige subtile
kation sein meint der wissenschaftliche
dienst also eine weitere übertragung der
verordnungsermächtigung dafür bräuchte
man eigentlich hat eine gesetzliche
grundlage die kids ihr nicht übertragen
dürfte man allenfalls auf
landesregierungen aber sicherlich nicht
auf der ki und dann verstoß gegen das
bestimmtheitsgebot sei der
wissenschaftliche dienst sagt zwar
verweisen können zwar grundsätzlich
zulässig sein wenn man halt trotzdem
sofort erkennen kann was diese norm
eigentlich jetzt regelt aber gerade weil
es halt so eine erhebliche grundrechts
relevanz hat der genesene nachweis und
man sich ja sogar ordnungswidrigkeit
ordnungswidrig verhält wenn man
plötzlich in der bahn keinen genießenden
nachweis mehr vorlegen kann dann kann es
halt auf keinen fall ausreichend dass
man so ein verwaister reinhaut in dem
man eigentlich nicht mehr so richtig
sagen kann was steht da jetzt eigentlich
drin und schließlich sagt der
wissenschaftliche dienst auch noch diese
verweisung ist eigentlich auch überhaupt
nicht erforderlich werden so schnell
werden neue wissenschaftliche
erkenntnisse mit denen das hat begründet
wird wahrscheinlich nicht kommen dass
man sagt hoch das müssen wir uns aber
heute nachmittag ändern denn auch die
verordnung selbst in der die
bundesregierung das eigentlich ja selbst
hätte regeln müssen muss ja schließlich
auch durch den bundestag und den
bundesrat also warum da jetzt plötzlich
so ein handlungsdruck sein sollte dass
man ausgerechnet bei den genesenen
nachweisen ich bin drei stunden per
änderung der webseite beim rk ii
reagieren können muss das sieht jetzt
der wissenschaften überhaupt nicht und
auch virologen sagen das ist auch
eigentlich gar nicht notwendig ich darf
da mal verweisen auf den interessanten
podcast für deutschland der gestern also
am dienstag erschienen ist wo es auch um
die lockerung debatte die lockerungs
debatten orgien rund um rom ikon geht
und da wurde ein bekannter virologe auch
explizit danach gefragt der wie sinnvoll
jetzt eigentlich die verkürzung ist und
er sagte auch relativ banal naja also
hängt ein bisschen davon ab was man
eigentlich möchte wenn es quasi darum
geht jegliche ansteckung zu vermeiden na
klar also dann kann man sagen nach drei
monaten wird es vielleicht ein bisschen
schwächer aber auch nach drei monaten
oder vier fünf sechs monaten ist der
schutz von der genesung so stark dass
man noch wenigstens von schweren
verläufen
sicher ist ja und darum geht es ja
letztendlich immer nur dass die leute
nicht im krankenhaus lang das haben wir
jetzt ja nun rauf und runter gesehen
natürlich die leute
stecken sich reihenweise an ich wundere
mich sowieso jeden tag warum es mich
noch nicht erwischt hat
ja oder also das ja eigentlich reine ein
reines glück gab's ja und da ist es doch
immer nur wichtig natürlich geht es auch
vielen leuten dreckig größe gehen raus
an jenen denen es erwischt hat aber
wichtig ist ja dass die leute nicht ins
krankenhaus müssen und dass sie auch
möglichst
ohne größere schäden da rauskommen das
hofft ja nun auch jeder also aber es das
war ja nicht das einzige sondern es ob
auch ein verwaltungsgericht das erste
verwaltungsgericht dass sich damit
auseinandergesetzt hat und gesagt hat
sie halten die ganze sache für
verfassungswidrig wer war das das war
das verwaltungsgericht in osnabrück und
die haben ganz ähnlich argumentiert was
er eben auf der auch auf der hand liegt
haben halt auch gesagt dieser verweis
geht so nicht dafür gibt es keine
rechtsgrundlage das sei alles
intransparent und zu unbestimmt die
haben komplett offen gelassen irgendwie
ob es nicht ohnehin parlamentsvorbehalt
bräuchte passiert auch nicht so
interessiert weil sie eben gesagt haben
jedenfalls dieser dynamische verweis
aufs ergebnis und die haben tatsächlich
auch gesagt in der sache gibt es auch
keine wissenschaftlich fundierte
grundlage für diese verkürzung das lka
habe das nicht nachgewiesen das finde
ich jetzt etwas merkwürdig dass als
verwaltungsgericht osnabrück zu
beschließen aber nicht ich könnte die
natürlich können die natürlich schon
sagen irgendwie so geht es nicht wir
halten das für verfassungswidrig das war
ein eilverfahren und die rechtsfolge ist
jetzt das verwaltungsgericht sagt wir
wenden dann die verordnung in der vorher
geltenden fassung an weil hat diese
änderung
verfassungswidrig war das bedeutet wir
gehen weiterhin davon aus dass die
genesungs frist sechs monate beträgt
aber nur bei dem einzelfall genau das
wirkt nur inter parkers also das halt
heißt es gilt nur für den antragsteller
und das ding ist auch noch nicht
rechtskräftig aber jetzt kommt jetzt ist
was ganz lustiges passiert berichten die
lokalen medien also dort ist es jetzt so
dass der landkreis hat auch die norm
weiterhin anwenden muss die kriegen aber
natürlich jeden tag hunderte anrufe und
die leute sagen was ist denn jetzt wir
haben schon gesagt bitte ruft uns nicht
mehr an wie machen sie jetzt oftmals so
dass sie den genesenden nachweis das
finde ich super für mindestens 90 tage
aus stellen und sagen so soll ein
längerer geltungszeitraum möglich
bleiben und wenn das dann auf
bundesebene wieder geändert wird auf die
180 tage dann ist ein nachweis
automatisch wieder 180 tage auch für die
menschen aus dem landkreis osnabrück das
ist alles schon echt ein bisschen wild
ja also man muss jetzt auch direkt an
herrn söder denken und an seiner
akrobatik das hier natürlich ein
bisschen eine andere situation hier ist
ja die behörde gefangen er hat zwischen
einem bestehenden recht dennis muss man
sagen bei in rechtlichen bedenken das
gilt im moment also der genießen status
ist verkürzt auf 90 tage punkt ja weil
sich also die länder müssen das schon
noch umsetzen da aber sie müssen es eben
auch umsetzen und das haben sie auch
alle gemacht also ich hab noch mal
nachgeguckt nrw hat jetzt vor ein paar
tagen irgendwie eingeführt berlin hat
der woche eingeführt und bayern hat
schon direkt am 23 januar gesagt wir
sind jetzt nur noch drei monate direkt
und ohne übergangsfristen und dabei sind
doch die bayern sonst recht flexibel was
da auf die auf bundesebene beschlossene
corona maßnahmen angeht oder corinna
kommen wir gleich noch dazu ich kann
vielleicht auch noch mal sagen was ja
auch für zunder gesorgt hat ist ja dass
im bundestag wiederum die sechs monate
gelten also da dürfen genesene auch noch
bis zum ablauf von sechs monaten sein
und in den plenarsaal gehen müssen nicht
auf die tribüne und
sind schon dinge die kommunikativ
schwierig war mit ja und da sagt
natürlich auch der vize-präsident des
parlamentes wolfgang kubicki von der fdp
daher ohnehin auch ein ziemlicher
kritiker von einen impfpflicht es
durchaus auch crooner maßnahmen der
ziemlich klar sagt na ja also das ist
nun mal das hausrecht ja das ist
insofern eine andere situation als es
hier ja darum geht dürfen die den
bundestag betreten und dass es dann eine
regelung die der bundestag selber
treffen darf und sich auf sechs monate
geeinigt hat und seitdem übrigens auch
nicht geändert hat und das ist insofern
ein sich in sich schlüssiges system und
umgekehrt sagt er natürlich naja also
tut mir fürchterlich leicht wenn jetzt
auch nicht gewählt das sozusagen
zurückzunehmen beziehungsweise auf die
drei monate zu beschränken denn ich
halte das auch nicht für sinnvoll das zu
tun und offensichtlich auch niemand
sonst im bundestag hat sie auch in der
interessante feststellung ja also das
heißt da geht auch völlig legitim die
sechs monate während dann bei im
einzelhandel man nach 90 tagen bzw drei
monaten dann schon wieder der tür
verwiesen wird es sei denn die
zweijährige wird aufgehoben was ja auch
immer häufiger jetzt geschieht
also in der haard ich glaube also ich
weiß gar nicht wie viele bundesländer
mittlerweile schon komplett raus sind
ich meinen einige haben das nach
gerichtlichen entscheidungen getan
andere haben dann gesagt auch kommen
wenn die wenn die anderen raus gehen
dann gehen wir auch raus da ist zweig
also im einzelhandel würde ich sagen
kann man im moment schon sagen löst sich
auf
das wird irgendwie genauso zur rechts
historien gehören wie
erinnerst du dich noch an die diese
click and click in mietsache leckt
klicken ja sowas
das war ja auch so eine kurze episode wo
apps auf einmal geschaffen wurden aus
dem boden gestampft wurden und dann
einen monat später
brauchte das keine sau mehr
weil auch zu recht kein mensch einkaufen
gegangen ist so wer will sie schon
shoppen gehen und welche collect hier
einfach auch nicht mehr brauche jetzt
gibt es richtige sagt zweig und das auch
das bald schon nicht mehr nun gut also
dass zu dieser posse ich hoffe übrigens
wir wollen wir jetzt nicht zu übermütig
albern klingen aber man verliert hier
manchmal doch so ein bisschen den
glauben finde ich oder in dieser ganzen
pandemie ist wird auch nicht besser so
dass also es wird ehrlich gesagt
schlechter und und gerade so mit blick
darauf dass eben die die neue regierung
ja eigentlich sich auf die fahne
geschrieben hatte dass man alles stärker
wieder im parlament und in der
öffentlichkeit diskutieren möchte und so
sind halt diese entwicklung schon
insgesamt sehr unerfreulich also da ist
schon so viel vorschuss finde ich den
mann der neuen bundesregierung gerade
mit blick darauf gegeben hat der wird
gerade recht verspielt ja das kann man
so sagen und die opposition macht das
auch gar nicht besser da kommen wir
jetzt nämlich dazu denn also mich hat
ehrlich gesagt ziemlich kalt erwischt am
montag als markus söder der
ministerpräsident von bayern raushaut
er hatte erhebliche bedenken was die
einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht angeht
und er würde das ganze jetzt erst einmal
auf eis legen da ist jetzt auch mal
wichtig bei allem ist übrigens immer
wichtig genau auf die formulierung zu
gucken denn die findet auch offen
besprechen und dann wird auch gerne
aneinander vorbeigeredet deswegen
versuchen wir hier jetzt mal sehr
präzise zu sein
da hieß es also bayern will jetzt nun
seinen eigenen weg gehen bei der
einrichtungs bezogenen impfpflicht und
großzügigste übergangsregelung gelten
lassen und das bedeutet dass es in
seinem bundesland de facto zunächst
einmal auf ein aussetzen des vollzugs
hinaus läuft ja
übrigens vielleicht auch mal vorneweg
also was wir jetzt hier berichten es
finde ich kann man da kann man schon
eine wichtige lehre daraus ziehen man
immer politiker über rechtliche bedenken
sprechen rechtliche unsicherheiten
zitieren oder eine klarheit der regelung
vermissen lassen und
deshalb etwas nicht tun wollen kann man
nur sagen liebe hörerinnen und hörer
seien sie wachsam
das ist meist nur vorgeschoben und wir
kommen gleich dahin wo es worum es
vielleicht eigentlich geht das natürlich
dann auch ein bisschen spekulation aber
ich würde sagen ich habe hier schon sehr
intensiv mit den kollegen auf dem flug
gesprochen da ist eine menge musik drin
und das wird auch tatsächlich für die
allgemeine impfpflicht nicht einfacher
das kann man muss man ja gar nicht
bedauern aber es ist jedenfalls so
vielleicht schauen wir jetzt erst mal
worum es eigentlich geht kurz mal zu
faktenlage also ab dem 16 märz 2022 geht
in medizinischen und pflegerischen
einrichtungen eine einrichtungs bezogene
impfpflicht das ganze ist ein gesetz das
in kraft getreten ist am 12 dezember und
zwar mit den stimmen der opposition so
und das war ja mit den stimmen der union
ja um das noch mal so zu betonen und da
kann man ja sagen da war ja ich finde
ich auch eine interessante debatte die
war ja ist relativ geräuschlos ist die
über die bühne gegangen wenn wir uns
erinnern haben wir auch kaum groß
diskutiert es war etwas was ziemlich
klar
verabschiedet wurde und alle haben sich
immer nur auf die allgemeine impfpflicht
konzentriert und na ja also ich finde
die pflegekräfte und sozusagen oder oder
eben andere kräfte die davon betroffen
sind die haben sich ja schon relativ
laut zur wehr gesetzt und haben gesagt
wir fühlen uns davon diskriminiert aber
es gab eigentlich jetzt so wieder auf
der politischen noch auf der rechtlichen
ebene ernsthafte zweifel daran dass man
so wollte und auch für verfassungsgemäß
hier also hab ich auch so empfohlen und
vielleicht um das noch einmal deutlich
zu sagen weil auch wo der unterschied
auch liegt zur allgemeine impfpflicht es
ist ja nun mal so dass diese person
unmittelbar mit den variablen gruppen zu
tun haben ja mit den 60 70 80 jährigen
oder auch mit denen die im krankenhaus
liegen und ohnehin schon
in schwierigen körperlichen
situation stecken womöglich krebs haben
was auch immer klar müssen die besonders
vor ansteckung geschützt werden das war
man die rad zu dahinter und das wurde
auch vehement verteidigt aber nun
scheint es eben so zu sein dass
insbesondere der opposition dämmert was
das arbeitsrechtlich bedeutet nämlich es
kann am ende die kündigung stehen ja
aber vielleicht noch mal einen schritt
zurück die regelung ist übrigens in §
20a
infektionsschutzgesetz wird auch da
wieder für diejenigen die es ganz genau
wissen wollen welche einrichtungen sind
betroffen das geht nämlich in der tat
schon wirklich ziemlich weidner also
pflegeeinrichtungen
behinderteneinrichtungen medizinische
rehabilitationseinrichtung reha könnte
man einfach auch sagen volante
pflegedienste aber übrigens auch freie
berufe sowie diätassistenten
ergotherapeutin hebammen logopäden
massen otto peso eigentlich schon so der
gesamte gesundheitssektor im weitesten
inklusive praktikanten alle
ehrenamtliche personen übrigens auch
weil die art der beschäftigung also ob
es eine arbeitsvertrag ist laie
arbeitsverhältnis praktikum
beamtenverhältnis oder das total
schnuppe und auch alle anderen tätigen
personen also will sagen hausmeister
transport personal küchenpersonal
reinigungspersonal alle genau also es
ging mir nur um die pflegekräfte sondern
um alle die dort arbeiten also alle eben
die potenziell mit diesen variablen
personen in berührung kommen können
genau und da ist es jetzt eben einfach
so wie funktioniert das ganze also
stichtag ist der 15 märz bis dahin
müssen alle diese person
gegenüber der jeweiligen
einrichtungsleitungen oder der und das
unternehmensführung ein nachweis bringen
dass sie geimpft sind da müssen wir
einfach das ding vorlegen wenn das nicht
passiert oder wenn es zweifel gibt an
der rechtmäßigkeit des nachweises muss
die behördenleitung entschuldige bitte
die einrichtungsleitung das dem
gesundheitsamt melden ja und sagen hier
haben wir 123 personen
auch mit namen und und den vollständigen
daten die nicht geimpft werden daraufhin
musste und dann gesundheitsamt tätig
werden und mit den klären ob es
ausnahmen gibt
entweder weil die chinesen sind weil sie
eine allergie haben weil sie andere was
auch immer noch so viele möglichkeiten
gibt es ja nicht aber das wird erstmal
geprüft so und wenn das alles
nicht vorliege nicht der fall ist genau
dann kann die das gesundheitsamt erstmal
ein
tätigkeitsverbot aussprechen und auch
ein betretungsverbot
ja und was bedeutet das konkret
die leute kriegen keine kohle also
wirklich leute können nicht arbeiten
gehen wir kriegen doch kein geld genau
so und dann kann man immer noch drüber
sprechen also das ist schon erstmal
natürlich ein ziemlicher einschnitt ja
ziemlich krasse konsequenz auf der
anderen seite kann man auch sagen wer
sonst könnte man sich auch sparen also
mein baum sollst du dann trotzdem
irgendwelche leute rein lassen wenn du
der meinung dass du brauchst das so und
das interessante ist jetzt dass herr
söder
sagte es sind einfach noch zu viele
dinge offen und das sagt übrigens auch
nicht nur herr söder sondern auch die
cdu als ganzes in gestalt des neuen
parteivorsitzenden
herrn friedrich merz der übrigens beide
juristen und die sagen im wesentlichen
ist noch viel zu viel unklar ja also
rechtliche bedenken arbeitsrechtliche
bedenken da wissen wir alles noch gar
nicht so genau wie die folgen sind
und ich würde wirklich mal sagen das
quatsch
denn es ist eigentlich relativ viel klar
ich habe gestern abend zum beispiel auch
mal mit
mit gregor thüsing gesprochen das ist
ein arbeitsrechtler der uni bonn der
einfach wirklich nur gesagt habe er
versteht auch die aufregung nicht er hat
es salopp formuliert war da
und hat er auch gesagt also selbst beim
gesundheitsamt halten sich die hält sich
der arbeitsaufwand in grenzen nicht mehr
arbeitsaufwand als beim knöllchen zum
beispiel weil eigentlich es relativ klar
ist was passiert ja also du hast ja
nicht besonders viel spielraum entweder
hat jemand was ein nachweis oder hat ihn
eben nicht und entweder hat eine
ausnahme hat kein so und da kann gut
aber das sind ja jetzt die ämter aber es
geht ja jetzt vor allem der union
natürlich auch um die unternehmen ja man
muss ehrlicherweise sagen also der union
geht es um so viel unterschiedliche
dinge also es wird mal arbeitsrechtliche
bedenken zitiert es werden weil die
überlastung der gesundheitsämter zitiert
das ist auch etwas was zum beispiel
glaub ich herrn müller auch sehr viel
sorgen bereitete und er habe volker
bouffier ministerpräsident von hessen
der übrigens ja in unserem sommer
ausgabe des mvz einspruch podcast zu
allgemeine impfpflicht er noch sich
machen wir mit dabei war vergangene
woche wollte dir gleich zum ersten märz
einführen sagt jetzt bei nach
einrichtungs bezogenen im pflicht sagt
moment ja da gibt es noch viele
arbeitsrechtliche fragen die wir klären
müssen zum beispiel ob es
lohnfortzahlung geben kann da muss man
ganz klar sagen nein also warum das ist
ja das ist ja quatsch wenn jemand nicht
arbeiten kann dann muss natürlich auch
kein geld gezahlt werden was man dann im
nächsten schritt fragen kann aber ich
finde diese frage auch gar nicht so
unfassbar relevant kann derjenige auch
gekündigt werden also da übrigens wäre
da vielleicht anderer meinung ist oder
so natürlich immer gerne bei uns auch
die meinung abladen und mitteilen unter
einspruch podcast faz.de ja aber wie
gesagt bei der kündigung könnte man noch
argumentieren also da müsste man
vielleicht eine abmahnung vorgeschaltet
werden da kann man auch mal gucken je
nachdem wann es stattfindet das ganze
ist ja übrigens auch befristet die
impfpflicht bis zum ersten januar 20 23
ja also wir sagen wir reden jetzt hier
um diese die nächsten neun monate könnte
man sagen es vielleicht
unverhältnismäßig dann zu kündigen wenn
der arbeitgeber ähnlich nicht zahlen
muss dann könnte man das vielleicht
ruhen lassen ich weiß nicht wie das dann
konkret vor gericht läuft der oder ob
und wie gesagt auch diese notwendigkeit
gibt der kündigung aber ich letztendlich
an diesem einfachen mechanismus
impfnachweis
vorzeigen und dann
betretungsverbot und tätigkeitsverbot
aussprechen das scheint mir keine
besonders komplexe sache zu sein die
noch viel
ausgestaltungen bedarf also zumindest
nicht auf rechtlicher ebene also ich
glaube das ist ja eher zu der punkt dass
diese rechtlichen aspekte die da
herzlich glauben ich darf das mal so
deutlich sagen vorgeschoben werden
eigentlich keine sind weil die sind
eigentlich relativ klar und das war es
nicht klar ist na ja das kann man glaube
ich mit relativ wenig rechtlichem
aufwand lösen eine andere frage ist
natürlich kommen die unternehmen dann
klar oder kündigt dann die hälfte
herzliche person so und jetzt kommt wir
übrigens genau zu dem eigentlichen kern
des ganzen was er durchaus auch aber ein
bisschen verschämt
geäußert wird sind ja die
personalengpässe die da drohen also um
das mal ganz konkret zu formulieren so
wie es offensichtlich jetzt hier aber
auch nur selten formuliert wird sind wir
als gesellschaft in der lage zu ertragen
dass leute gekündigt wird oder dass sie
ihren job verlieren weil sie sich nicht
impfen lassen das ist ja die frage ja
und jemand wie karl lauterbach unser
neuer gesundheitsminister hat es
natürlich schon lange durchschaut und
hat damit kein problem hatten wir
letztens auch ein großes interview mit
ihm woher ganz klar gesagt leute die dem
wissenschaftlichen stand nicht trauen
die sich weigern zu impfen sich impfen
zu lassen die sind in diesem beruf
schlecht falsch der sagt
habe ich kein problem damit nun haben
wir aber die situation dass glaube im
krankenhausbereich sehr sehr viele
geimpft sind da sagt das rk ii sind 95
prozent also dafür dass auch wirklich
nur relativ kleinen kreis betreffen aber
es gibt wohl
einrichtungen insbesondere in sachsen
zum beispiel wo man damit rechnen muss
dass tatsächlich 30 prozent 20 30
prozent der leute nicht kämpft sind und
was macht man das führt natürlich zum
zusammenbruch des systems na das ist ja
klappen also wie funktioniert du wie
kannst du deine prozesse abwickeln wenn
plötzlich 30 prozent dann fehlt genau
also darum geht es letztendlich und da
ist sozusagen auch dies ist ein
zweischneidiges schwert also es sind
einerseits natürlich die
personalengpässe die die unternehmen
dann verkraften müssen auf der anderen
seite scheint mir auch so ein bisschen
mitzuschwingen ich weiß nicht ob das ist
sozusagen die motivation der cdu ist
aber den doch recht
scharfe konsequenz einer möglichen
kündigung in diesem bereich ehrlich
gesagt hält sich da jetzt irgendwie mein
verständnis dafür dass man das mitte
februar der avisierte ich denke absolut
also ich meine das ding ist im dezember
durchgewunken worden und zwar von allen
der zustimmung der union es wird doch
wohl klar sein dass wenn ich eine
impfpflicht verhänge eine einrichtungs
bezogene impfpflicht das dann derjenige
der sich nicht impfen lässt eben
notfalls auch gekündigt werden kann
zumindest aber nicht arbeiten kann und
keinen lohn bekommt also ist jetzt doch
keine überraschung da also für juristen
wahrscheinlich nicht aber ich könnte mir
vorstellen dass viele nicht so weit
gedacht haben beziehungsweise dass die
politik sich auch schlicht
verkalkuliert hatte dass die so dachten
okay jetzt werden wir mal mit der
einrichtungs bezogenen impfpflicht dann
werden die leute schon zu den
impfzentren rennen hat ja auch zum
bestimmten raane geklappt also wir haben
ja nun auch durchaus steigerungen
gesehen bei der impfbereitschaft aber es
ist eben nicht so durchschlagen wie sich
das wahrscheinlich viele erhofft haben
und alles kann ich mir ehrlich gesagt
nicht erklären dass juristen wie zum
beispiel herr bouffier dann so einem
schwammigen arbeitsrechtlichen bedenken
zitiert mit der wii die frage der
lohnfortzahlung die einfach meines
erachtens wirklich kein problem
darstellt sondern eigentlich von der
debatte ablenkt also ich finde es auch
interessant weil markus söder und auch
herr merz der die ganze zeit jetzt davon
ausgehen wir müssen jetzt noch ein paar
sachen klären
klarstellen im gesetz und die
arbeitsrechtlichen konsequenzen ja aber
wenn wir das getan habe und wenn von mir
aus darin drinsteht dass auch
kündigungen möglich sind das macht die
sache jetzt nicht besser also es 0
änderte und nach meinem sachstand hat
die cdu doch jetzt auch schon gefordert
die im einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht
erst mal bundesweit aus zu haus zu
gesetzen genau
auszusetzen und man kann übrigens auch
noch mal sagen also die unter juristen
ist auch das was ich hier in der politik
abspielt wirklich also wird hier nicht
besonders gut ihr tja also der krampf
scharfer gegenwind zum beispiel vom
präsidenten des bundessozialgerichts
rainer schlegel der ganz klar gesagt hat
also das geht so nicht nur dass bayern
einfach sagte werden das nicht
vollziehen das ist ne total schräge
nummer kommen wir übrigens auch gleich
noch was
der bund habe noch was dagegen tun kann
gegen diesen seelischen verfassung
wie die eto das formuliert hat den chip
online
aber das ist schon wir sind im moment in
einer ganz schwierigen situation und vor
allen dingen eine in der
interessanterweise alle dann noch immer
sagen ja aber an der allgemeinen
impfpflicht halten wir noch fest
ja mir erschließt sich das auch nicht so
richtig ist er denn man würde halt dann
mit den konsequenzen argumentieren weil
ich meine wenn wir jetzt einerseits
sagen alle sind plötzlich total
überrascht davon dass die einrichtungs
bezogen der impfpflicht konsequenzen hat
nämlich die harte konsequenz dass
menschen gekündigt werden können da
müsste man sich natürlich fragen das wie
inwiefern wäre das denn anders bei der
allgemeinen pflicht und natürlich würde
da jetzt im zweifel ist nicht sofort
bedeuten dass jeder mensch gekündigt
wird warum auch es ist ja durchaus auch
möglich muss man in vielen bürgern auf
aber auch nicht in hallen richtig ich
bin aber in der sache total bei dir
corinna also wie man die einrichtungs
bezogen der impfpflicht irgendwie
zumindest aussetzen
können will wollen kann und auf der
anderen seite sagt die allgemeine
impfpflicht finden wir aber weiterhin
gut erschließt sich mir auch nicht
jetzt aber vielleicht jetzt noch einmal
zu den juristischen konsequenzen also
das ist ja schon erstaunlich dass bayern
jetzt oder bayern was heißt bayern dass
markus söder seines zeichen ja übrigens
auch der ehemalige anführer des teams
vorsicht er ist aber offenbar nicht mehr
so vorsichtig sondern wie ich nicht als
heute titze team scheiß drauf das war
nicht wirklich sehr sehr schön dass also
markus söder jetzt sagt wir setzen mal
den vollzug irgendwie de facto aus weil
man wir sprechen immer noch vom
bundesgesetz du hast das gesagt das soll
in vier wochen ungefähr in kraft treten
kann da jetzt bayern einfach kommen und
sagen ohne doch nicht eigentlich
natürlich überhaupt nicht nur das ist
sind auch einigermaßen die leute
fassungslos wir haben wie gesagt um das
mal deutsch zu sagen es ist ja keine
besonders neue
situation also wir haben ein
bundesgesetz § 20a des
infektionsschutzgesetzes
dass ausländer ebene vollzogen werden
muss das gibt es täglich rauf und runter
ja und wie gesagt sehr ungewöhnlich dass
ein bundesland mal sagt machen wir
einfach nicht weil zuviel unklaren und
außerdem werden sind unsere gesundheit
ämter überlastet mir übrigens wie das
mitte märz aussieht wenn hoffentlich die
omikron welle schon an uns vorbei oder
über kunst rollt ist ist er dann auch
noch mal eine ganz andere frage
vielleicht also spätestens april mai
wird ja dann wird hinter einem
gesundheitsamt wieder die überstunden
abgebaut so also das ist eine sehr
ungewöhnliche konstellation dass sich
der ein land so explizit wert und das
übrigens fand ich auch deswegen so
interessant weil es auch gar nicht
notwendig ist so was an die große glocke
zu hängen also auch da wieder deutet
alles darauf hin dass würde hier groß
auf populismus macht weil er man kann so
was ja auch stillschweigender beerdigen
also haben wir ja gesehen was in corona
zeiten alles nicht gemacht hat nicht
vollzogen wurde der ist die latte
wahrscheinlich extrem lang ja und hier
hätte man natürlich auch sagen können
wäre auch möglich gewesen dass sie der
sich eben hinstellen sagt jetzt warten
wir erst mal ab und gucken wie es so
läuft und so weiter und dann wird eben
nicht im april gewarnt sondern irgendwie
die ersten die ersten papiere die ersten
bescheide gehen dann erst im mai raus
und so weiter und so fort also der ist
ja gibt es ja eine ganze reihe von
möglichkeiten wie man das
praxis konform gestalten kann so aber
jetzt gibt es natürlich unter juristen
das wollten wir ihnen das wollen wir
euch nicht vorenthalten verschiedene
szenarien was der bank im bund machen
kann ich sage vorneweg als ist klemm
hatte ist sind so ein bisschen
theoretische gedankenspiele würde ich
jetzt mal sagen kann mir nicht
vorstellen
dass das tatsächlich passieren wird aber
es ist ja durchaus auch interessant dass
das grundgesetz da verschiedene
dinge vorsicht denn man muss sagen es
gibt ja also das rechtsstaatsprinzip in
der bundesrepublik auch dass die bund
länder treue sozusagen also die tatsache
dass man sich sicher nicht gegenseitig
an den karren fährt das sind ja alles
grundprinzipien die auch im grundgesetz
ihrer verankerung finden so und da ist
eben auch festgelegten artikel 84 absatz
3 des grundgesetzes dass die länder ein
bundesgesetz als eigene angelegenheit
auszuführen haben ja und wenn das sich
schwierigkeiten bereitet dann kann die
bundesregierung einen beauftragten zu
den obersten landesbehörden in senden ja
und zwar mit zustimmung der
landesregierung wird hier dann
wahrscheinlich nicht passieren oder aber
mit dem bundesrat übrigens vielleicht an
dieser stelle könnte man noch mal sagen
ich beziehe mich auf einen ganz famosen
aufsatz der wie gesagt bei lte und dr
patrick heinemann veröffentlicht wurde
verwaltungsrechtler aus freiburg so der
das mal schön dargelegt und hat die
verschiedenen möglichkeiten
aufgelistet so und das ist so ein
bisschen dieser bundes beauftragt ist
dass es ein bisschen nutzlos weil es da
eigentlich im wesentlichen nur darum
geht dass man unterrichtet würde oder
auskunft verlangen kann ja also das
hilft dann natürlich nicht besonders
aber stellt eben das land die
festgestellten mängel nicht ab kann der
bundesrat also auch wieder die
länderkammer auf antrag der
bundesregierung beschließen dass das
land das recht verletzt hat also in
jenen antike 84 das grundgesetz ist so
und ging einen solchen beschluss kann
wiederum das bundesverfassungsgericht
angerufen werden also da würde herr
söder aber tatsächlich in karlsruhe auf
der matte stehen das kann man sich schon
vorstellen so dann gebe es aber auch die
möglichkeit dass die bundesregierung
selbst beim bundesverfassungsgericht
vorstellig wird und dort eben beantragen
kann eine pflichtverletzung des von
bayern bei der ausführung von
bundesrecht feststellen zu lassen also
das ist eben der zweite weg so und das
sind jetzt ist ehrlich gesagt so ein
bisschen vorgeplänkel die frage ist
natürlich auch immer an inwieweit auch
der sogenannte bundes zwang
eingefordert werden kann oder eingeführt
werden kann bundes zwang ist natürlich
auch ein ganz herzliches rechtsinstitut
was eben auch in der theorie herrliches
worte her da kann im grünen nahmen die
bundesregierung hin gehen und auch
braucht da die zustimmung des bundesrat
und kann dann die notwendigen maßnahmen
treffen um das land zur erfüllung seiner
pflichten anzuhalten ja und dann könnte
man auch da wieder ein bundes kommissar
einsetzen ja der in dem betroffenen land
und jetzt ist das tatsächlich nächste
eskalationsstufe die exekutivgewalt an
sich reißt ja gut ich glaube wir können
irgendwie sagen jetzt noch gonna have
her oder
ich habe jetzt auch noch niemanden sagen
hören dass das irgendwie passieren soll
karl lauterbach hat sich sehr konstant
gezeigt gegenüber der ankündigung von
markus söder aber ich habe bisher noch
niemanden sagen hören dass darüber
nachgedacht wird wie bundes zwang
anzuwenden
gegenüber bayern hast du eine prognose
wie das alles jetzt weitergeht
ganz ehrlich da bin ich blank also ich
da bin ich wirklich wirklich lang also
letztendlich ist es ja so ich würde ich
denke die einrichtungs bezogene
impfpflicht wird kommen also ich glaube
jetzt nicht dass nach diesem theater die
ampel regierung da klein beigibt und
sagte okay wenn die union das jetzt sagt
dann setzen wir den kram lieber mal aus
das wird nicht kommen und gleichzeitig
dann wird's in bayern keine konsequenzen
haben vielleicht gehen dann die sachsen
alle nach bayern könnte ja sein
[Gelächter]
könnte sein genau dann kann man halt
vielleicht vorübergehend dort arbeiten
will aber meine pflegekräftemangel
gibt's ja gegen absolut aber wenn du
prognose wäre tatsächlich das jetzt
jetzt irgendwie mit der allgemeinen
impfpflicht also das würde mich wundern
wenn jetzt noch umgekommen würde ich
glaube die ist tot ich weiß nicht ob das
jetzt ein bisschen verfrüht ist diese
kühne these weil es ist ja wirklich viel
dynamik drin und wir merken immer wieder
dass zwei monate später die sachlage
schon wieder ganz anders aussieht aber
das ist so ein bisschen
meine prognose hast du von mir gibt es
dazu absolut kein widerspruch ich glaube
schon seit zwei drei wochen dass es
extrem schwierig wird also allein
kommunikativ und politisch gesehen mal
völlig unabhängig von der juristischen
ausformulierung
das ganze dann irgendwie zu einem
zeitpunkt anzustoßen wo die omikron
welle gerade wieder abflacht und alle
nach lockerungen schreien also ich halte
das für faktisch unmöglich aber gut wir
sind ja schon oft überrascht doch
absolut gut jetzt können wir aber mal
zum anderen thema
bitte jetzt gibt's zum bgh der hatte
sich mit einer ganz anderen thematik zu
beschäftigen erzählt nochmal ja und zwar
mit einem relativ üblen fall aus der
rockerszene aus dem jahr 2014
damals haben acht mitglieder der hells
angels also erkennt diese rocker gang
wie der bgh schrieb überfallartig ein
wettbüro im berliner stadtteil
reinickendorf gestürmt das war das
stammlokal des damaligen rivalen des
anführers und der hatte seinen acht
jungs ich vermute es waren nur jungs da
dürfen glaube ich nur männer mitmachen
am nachmittag desselben tages mit dieser
tat beauftragt eben weil das sein rivale
da war also laufen die zu acht man da
rein und der typ sitzt da arglos rum wie
das landgericht berlin dann beurteilt
hat und wird sofort über den haufen
geschossen also sofort tot das
landgericht berlin hat darin einen mord
gesehen also klar heimtücke und aus
niedrigen beweggründen alles sehr
naheliegend alle acht verurteilt und den
anführer wegen anstiftung zum mord so
weit so klar aber das landgericht berlin
hat dann gesagt es gibt jetzt ein
vollstreckungsabkommen zwei jahren also
die mindestverbüßungszeit der strafe
also 15 jahre leben seine
freiheitsstrafe für mord gilt in höhe
von 2 jahren als bereits vollstreckt es
fallen also quasi zwei jahre der strafe
weg obwohl man sie halt noch nicht
verbüßt hat behandeln srg medien hat
genau die haben gesagt sie gehen davon
aus dass die angeklagten verletzt wurden
sind in ihrem recht auf ein faires
verfahren also das ist artikel 6 absatz
1 europäische menschenrechtskonvention
und zwar weil achtung jetzt kommt es
wohl sein kann dass das
landeskriminalamt in berlin schon im
oktober 2013 also monate davor gewusst
hat dass der dieser rivale getötet
werden sollte und nichts dagegen
unternommen hat
so und dann haben die überall straff
abschläge vorgenommen und haben gesagt
hat zwei jahre weniger
staatsanwaltschaft ist in revision
gegangen alles in den revision gegangen
übrigens alle angeklagten haben verloren
einer hat so ein ganz kleines bisschen
gewonnen aber im prinzip nicht wichtig
die staatsanwaltschaft aber hat gewonnen
die hat gegen diesen sogenannten
vollstreckungsaufschub region eingelegt
jetzt mal ganz kurzer exkurs für die
jura nerds vollstreckungsaufschub was
ist das resultiert aus dem jahr 2008 und
wurde vom bgh erfunden eigentlich für
rechtsstaatswidrig
verfahrensverzögerungen also wenn
ermittlungs und strafverfahren so ewig
dauern dass die angeklagten faktisch
jahrelang zb in u-haft sitzen meine ewig
auf ihren prozess warten und so hat der
bgh im jahr 2008 aufgrund ganz viel
hässlicher detail strafrechtlicher
streitigkeiten dann gesagt das ist dazu
machen wir die vollstreckung lösung also
wir sehen einfach ein teil der
ausgeteilten strafe als vollstreckt an
so und das hat das lg jetzt in diesem
fall auch gemacht hat gesagt ja kein
sein das hätte der staat verhindern
können kommt aber nicht so häufig vorne
also es war jetzt der bgh dass sozusagen
vorgemacht jetzt sagt das landgericht
können wir auch mal versuchen klingt
ganz gut aber genau für einen ganz
anderen fall aber hat der bgh jetzt
zumindest wenn man der pressemitteilung
glauben darf bei kurzen prozess gemacht
und gesagt nichts gibt keine verletzung
der angeklagten in ihrem recht auf ein
faires verfahren aus artikel 6 es gibt
keinen vollstreckungsaufschub bei einer
verurteilung wegen mordes weil der staat
den mord möglicherweise hätte verhindern
können da sagt der bgh sehr kurz und
knapp straftäter haben keinen anspruch
darauf dass die strafverfolgung organe
gegen sie selbst einschreiten ich finde
ich glaube es geht nicht und dann haben
wir halt sofort den rechtsfolgen
ausspruch des landgerichts aufgehoben
das heißt dieser vollstreckung abschlag
entfällt jetzt damit die zwei jahre sind
also faktisch oben wieder oben drauf die
staatsanwaltschaft hat diesbezüglich
komplett gewonnen und die rocker haben
alle komplett verloren das lief nicht
gut für die man ihn und auch durchaus
nachvollziehbar hätte auch unsere
gerechtes urteil werden können ja
absolut das sehe ich schon auch so
irgendwie ist es sehr merkwürdig dass
das den täter zu gute kommen sollte dass
der staat ihn nicht wie geschehen das
wäre eine wirklich schräge konstellation
das nur mal so ein bisschen weil man
sich durchaus vorstellen kann dass es so
ein bisschen als also wird question in
mündlichen prüfungen oder so vorkommt
fand ich sehr spannend guckt euch auch
mal an waren es normalerweise
vollstreckungsabkommen falls im wahlfach
strafrecht müsst ihr das wissen ihr
hasen darauf
channel in chester also alte chemiker
und maschinenbauer und ärztinnen da
draußen die uns zuhören an die natürlich
auch ein besonders herzliches schaut
aber das ist ja auch durchaus
interessant zu wissen wann es mal
verstrickung abschlag gibt und wann
nicht
und jetzt kommen wir zu einem weiteren
man kann schon fast sagen leidigen thema
das sich seit monaten und jahren
hinzieht in diesem fall geht es um den
bundesfinanzhof der hat jetzt seit ein
paar wochen immerhin einen neuen
präsidenten aber die stelle der
vizepräsident tim in diesem fall bleibt
weiterhin unbesetzt das hat der
bayerische verwaltungsgerichtshof in
dieser woche beschlossen
anke morsch wird nicht vizepräsidentin
und das ganze verfahren muss jetzt neu
aufgerollt werden corinna worum geht es
genau das ist jetzt der aktuelle anlass
für uns uns dass man eher anzugucken
denn das ist etwas was die richterschaft
wirklich schon seit langer langer zeit
nicht nur beschäftigt sondern
richtiggehend empört und das ist
eigentlich auch ein schöner fall wo wir
mal erzählen kann wie politik und
insbesondere die höchsten richter ämter
jedoch miteinander verwoben sind das
wird vielleicht viele juristen auf und
vor allen dingen viele nichtjuristen
auch durchaus verwundern vielleicht auch
empören denn es liefert jedenfalls immer
wieder auch
anlass für diskussionen und für kritik
und für den wunsch das ganze doch mal zu
ändern aber ich kann vielleicht mal
vorweg nehmen dieses glaube nicht dass
dieses system sich geändert wir haben
nämlich einfach es geht schlicht und
ergreifend um machtfragen auch um
parteipolitische macht tragen die bis
hoch zu den spitzen der jeweiligen
bundesgerichts ranken man kann
vielleicht um damalige disclaimer vor zu
machen er jetzt hier alle in also
komplette empörung unterstützen das hat
in der
rechtsprechung hat es kein niederschlag
na also wir sind hier nicht in den
vereinigten staaten wo man auch er in
den vergangenen jahren immer wieder
gesehen hat wie politisch auch diese
ganzen richter wahlen ablaufen auch wie
unverhohlen parteipolitisch das ist bei
uns wesentlich diskreter und man kann
vor allen dingen wenn die herren und
damen einmal im amt sind tatsächlich in
der rechtsprechung findet das auch keine
niederschlag würde ich sagen also da
sind auch die menschen die der berufen
werden so unabhängig dass da keine
gefahr ist aber in den vereinigten
staaten haben wir schon gesehen und auch
auf diskutiert ist das eben anders und
von polen möchte jetzt gar nicht erst
anfangen ehrlich gesagt weil dieser
vergleich wird und es auch oft gezogen
arbeit also der führt nun weiß gott in
ihrer deswegen wollen wir den hier auch
nicht vertiefen also worum geht es
eigentlich eine ganz harmlose sache wir
hatten vor anderthalb jahren eine große
verabschiedung von dem damaligen
präsidenten des bundesfinanzhofes rudolf
mellinghoff der übrigens früher auch
verfassungsrichter war und deswegen uns
auch in der sendung zu 70 jahre
bundesverfassungsgericht hier rede und
antwort gestanden hat er dieses
interview noch einmal nachhören möchte
also dessen nachfolge war lange unklar
bzw
sie war politisch umstritten rudolf
mellinghoff ist im august grafik 2020 in
rente gegangen wenig später sein
vizepräsident und seitdem ist dieses
haus weitgehend führungslos gewesen und
warum war das so weil die damalige
schwarz-rote regierung ein personalpaket
geschnürt hat und
ab redet hat dass der cdu-kandidat
hans-josef
kießling ist er ist nämlich
spitzenbeamter gewesen bis vor kurzem im
nordrhein westfälischen
finanzministeriums zuvor natürlich auch
richter
und vor allen dingen präsident des
finanzgerichts düsseldorf also
selbstverständlich hat er eine lange
wieder aus in der justiz aber am
bundesfinanzhof war er bisher noch nicht
und als vize präsidentin hat die spd
anke marsch ins rennen geschickt auch
sie natürlich richterin aber auch
ehemalige saarländische spd
justizstaatssekretärin also eben auch da
ein politischer bezug und auch sie keine
richterin am bundesfinanzhof und das war
in der tat immer der stein des anstoßes
denn es gibt ihm eine liste von
anforderungen die an die spitze oder bei
der berufung an die spitze von solchen
bundesgerichten
festgelegt sind und das schöne daran
dass uns das sind sehr unterschiedliche
anforderungen darunter übrigens auch die
gender kompetenz
ja diese sollte man nicht nein aber
tatsächlich ein präsident eine
präsidentin eines bundesgerichtes muss
auch so etwas wie gender kompetenz
aufweisen ich wäre zwar sehr gespannt
auf den nachweis aber grundsätzlich kann
ich das natürlich erst mal total
befürworten ja genau aber da drin in
dieser liste stand bisher auch dass
mindestens eine fünfjährige tätigkeit
als richter am jeweiligen bundesgericht
vorliegen muss wir hatten schon gesagt
wieder bei von herrn kiessling noch bei
frau morsch war dies der fall
interessanterweise hat das aber auch vor
allen dingen bei frau
für ärger gesorgt unter der
richterschaft die fühlten sich sozusagen
da erstens nicht ernst genommen
übergangen und haben eben gesagt hier
ist die richterliche unabhängigkeit in
gefahr weil so offenkundig ist dass in
diesem fall hier die parteipolitik vor
der eignung steht ja und warum hat mir
das gesagt warum hatten die bei herrn
kiessling daher eben auch nicht am
bundesfinanzhof war kein problem damit
da wurde immer gesagt ein präsident hat
nicht so eine starke stellung als
richter ist also musste quasi also nicht
fachlich so stark tätig werden sondern
eher organisatorisch
insbesondere im revisionsrecht na also
auch der präsident hat ist ein den
vorsitz eines senates die
vize-präsidentin eben auch aber ich
finde das klang immer so ein bisschen
komisch so nach dem motto wenn der
präsident krieg candles und klein sind
oder jedenfalls einen wichtigen da ist
es nicht so wichtig dass er sich im
revisionsrecht ausgehend das hat niemand
natürlich so offiziell gesagt aber
schwang immer so ein bisschen mit in der
argumentation aber die vize präsidentin
hat eben nicht so viele repräsentative
aufgaben wie der präsident der ist auch
sehr viel mit
organisatorischen dingen betraut aber
die vize-präsidentin ist eben viel
stärker tatsächlich als richterin
inhaltlich angebunden genau deswegen
muss die da eben fit sein deswegen war
es insbesondere für frauen ein problem
aber nicht für den test links und dann
ging der ärger erst richtig los also es
kam zu hochrangigen gesprächen mit der
justizministerin christine lambrecht auf
deren mist das sozusagen gewachsen war
die hatte sich dieses
personalpaket mit zusammen mit der union
ausgedacht die hatten heute natürlich an
ihrer spd-frau auch festhalten
war ja wie gesagt sorgsam austariert und
dann war aber der unmut so groß beiden
unter der richterschaft auch übrigens an
den anderen bundesgerichten dass die
sich irgendwie zusammenraufen mussten
dann kam es zu einem gespräch wo es auch
insbesondere darum ging dass diese
anforderungen geändert werden sollten
also
dass da wollte eben christine lambrecht
generell auch mal etwas sehr
grundsätzliches ändern nicht nur jetzt
für den aktuellen fall sondern sie
wollte eigentlich diese anforderung
loswerden weil sie so ein bisschen das
gefühl hatte na ja da ist da kocht die
richterschaft schon sehr im eigenen saft
wenn dann sozusagen immer nur jemand von
innen kommen kann um an die spitze des
bundesgerichts zu kommen dann kommt er
auch nie in frischer wind rein kann man
jetzt auch kann man ja auch diskutieren
das ist jetzt erst mal nichts war wo man
per se wenn man das mal irgendwie von
unternehmen aussieht oder so sagen muss
das ist ja vollkommen absurd dass jemand
auch von externen da durchaus irgendwie
kompetenz reinbringen kann aber die vor
allem die die bundesrichterin und
bundesrichter sehen das wirklich ganz
anders und sind der auffassung dass es
definitiv eine mehrjährige erfahrung
braucht an dem jeweiligen bundesgericht
um das bundesgericht dann auch leiten zu
können
richtig und dieser streit ist quasi
wurde in die neue legislaturperiode
übertragen das lag dann auch daran dass
im grunde genommen ja dann auch immer
damit naja also von euch richter am
bundesfinanzhof gibt es einfach auch
niemanden der diese bestellung ausfüllen
kann das ist ja natürlich auch so ein
kleiner affront gewesen letztendlich
haben sich dann auch mehrere richter und
richterinnen zur wehr gesetzt und haben
diese typischen konkurrentenklagen
angestrebt vor den verwaltungsgerichten
in münchen das ist auch nicht eine
relativ ungewöhnliche sache das passiert
häufiger mal das hat auch dem bgh über
jahre hinweg an verschiedenen senaten
lahmgelegt dass da immer wieder
konkurrenten klage einlegen und an diese
stelle wollen und das war natürlich auch
bei herrn kiessling der fall da spielt
es allerdings eine geringere rolle die
wurde relativ kleine klage wurde relativ
schnell abgeräumt aber bei frau morsch
war das ein größeres thema da fühlten
sich offensichtlich mehrere richterinnen
und richter berufen und jetzt ist es
folgendermaßen aufgelöst dieser streit
dass dann
eine andere regierung an die macht kam
wir jetzt mit herrn buschmann als neun
bundesjustizminister offensichtlich
jemand haben der diese sache sehr sehr
pragmatisch sieht da jetzt auch nicht zu
sehr parteipolitisch vorgegangen ist
weil er den cdu-mann herrn kiessling
dann hat durchlaufen lassen also der da
hatte dann anders als bei lambrecht
nicht mehr auf dieses paket wert gelegt
hat auch nicht darauf wert gelegt deren
eigenen kandidaten zu präsentieren
sondern hat also vor rund 2-3 wochen
gesagt naja
jetzt brauchen wir da jemand an der
spitze hat ihn durchgewunken die
ernennungsurkunde wurde dann auch
gestellt und dann war die sache gegessen
und bei anke marsch ging es eben nicht
so schnell wie gesagt weil die
konkurrentenklagen noch anhängig waren
und da ist es jetzt
kam es tatsächlich zu einer niederlage
für das bundesjustizministerium muss man
ja sagen
will sagen die konkurrenten haben
obsiegt und da war einfach die recht
nüchterne recht nüchternen befund des
bayerischen verwaltungsgerichtshof der
gesagt hat diese benennung ist
fehlerhaft gewesen ja die
auswahlentscheidung genau richtig
offensichtlich ist er schon beim
leistungsvergleich mit den drei
konkurrenten was schief gelaufen hätte
das bundesjustizministerium wieder von
einem leichter noch von einem vorsprung
von frau marsch ausgehen dürfen und das
hat sich jetzt auch sehr formalistisch
an also es scheint mir auch so zu sein
als wäre schon quasi die ausschreibung
oder die begründung nicht besonders
sauber gewesen denn dass der bayerische
verwaltungsgerichtshof
führte auch aus dass da unklar geblieben
sei welches anforderungsprofil
zugrunde gelegt worden sei also im
bundesjustizminister buschmann wird
jetzt wahrscheinlich die sache noch
einmal neu aufrollen und vielleicht noch
mal aus gut eine entscheidung treffen
bis dahin wird es keinen
vize-präsidenten keine vize-präsidentin
geben aber immerhin hertie sling ist im
amt und kann da schon walten und
schalten wie er möchte und
die rechtsprechung
geht ja auch sein gang das war ja auch
schon vorher so also das jetzt zu dem
langen langen streit am bundesfinanzhof
und dann kommen wir zu den nachträgen
und da muss ich erst mal ein bisschen
sozusagen abbitte leisten weil ich in
der vergangenen woche zu dem urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichts zum fall
renate künast das ist ganz kurz vor der
aufzeichnung rein gekommen war da ich
mich mindestens unklar ausgedrückt habe
es ging um das urteil mit dem renate
künast ich sag mal ein etappensieg
errungen hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat zwei
berliner urteile aufgehoben
die renate künast in weiten teilen die
herausgabe von daten von facebook
nutzern und nutzerinnen verweigert
hatten
die hatten renate künast sehr übelst
beschimpft auf facebook und die dank
gerichte und auch das kg in berlin haben
gesagt in teilen sind diese
beschimpfungen keine beleidigungen und
deswegen hätte renate künast keinen
anspruch darauf dass sie eben die daten
bekommt gegen dieser dieser nutzerinnen
und nutzer um gegen die zivilrechtlich
vorzugehen und das
bundesverfassungsgericht ist als
reingehauen und hat gesagt dass die
berliner urteile renate künast in ihrem
persönlichkeitsrecht verletzt weil sie
eben das persönlichkeitsrecht von künast
nicht hinreichend beachtet hätten in der
abwägung zwischen meinungsfreiheit und
persönlichkeitsrecht das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat aber nicht
das will ich einfach nur noch mal
klarstellen entschieden dass diese üblen
beschimpfungen die ich da in der letzten
woche auch zum teil unerfreulich
ausführlich zitieren musste jetzt
beleidigungen sind und dass damit renate
künast automatischen anspruch hätte
darauf dass die daten dieser
beleidigenden menschen herausgegeben
werden das ist noch nicht entschieden
das wollte ich einfach nur noch mal
klarstellen das ist jetzt nur ein
zwischenschritt und die gerichte in
berlin das ist eben aufgabe der
instanzgerichte werden jetzt nochmal
darüber entscheiden ob das nun
beleidigungen waren oder ob das
irgendwie noch der meinungsfreiheit
unterliegen könnte trotzdem was das
bundesverfassungsgericht jetzt
entschieden hat da wollte ich jetzt
nicht vorgreifen das steht noch nicht
fest ob das beleidigend sind es ist ein
langer beschwerlicher weg für frau
künast und für alle anderen aber es ist
ja schon auch ein wichtiger etappensieg
jetzt für sie gewesen in karlsruhe denn
sie führt ja nun wirklich einen
herauszuheben kampf gegen hass und hetze
in sozialen netzwerken und das ist halt
echt ein langer weg und du warst fand
ich jetzt schon wichtig dass das
bundesverfassungsgericht das auch noch
mal zum anlass genommen hat um zu sagen
also nur weil leute irgendwie personen
des öffentlichen lebens sind gibt es
deshalb noch keine berechtigung sie
irgendwie persönlich total an zu finden
und das total unter der gürtellinie auf
persönlicher ebene gegen sie zu schießen
sehr richtig aber der drops ist noch
nicht gelutscht noch nicht genau richtig
gut dann kommen wir zu einer anderen
korrektur und die betrifft das facebook
urteil des bundesgerichtshof über das
ihr letzte woche gesprochen habt ihr du
und helene und
da haben wir die wirklich interessante
besonderheit dass wir hier eine
offensichtliche diskrepanz haben
zwischen dem nationalen recht dass
pseudonyme erlaubt also dass auch
deutlich festlegt der dienste-anbieter
muss pseudonyme ermöglichen und der
europäischen regelung nämlich den
europäischen datenschutz grund
verordnung die dazu schweigt und man
wird dieses schweigen ihm dahin gehen
dass man sagt
ja dann ist es wahrscheinlich auch nicht
erlaubt ja so und zumindest und auf
jeden fall gibt es auch kein recht dafür
und da hatte helene eben festgestellt
was ja auch sehr wichtig ist dass dieser
paragraf 13 des
telemediengesetzes im november quasi
weggefallen ist also diese
diese pflicht pseudonyme anzubieten gibt
es seitdem im telemediengesetz nicht
mehr allerdings gibt es eine ersatz norm
das ganze ist nämlich rüber gewandert in
paragraf 19 absatz 2 des und jetzt
kommt's des gesetzes über den
datenschutz in den schutz der
privatsphäre in der telekommunikation
und bei telemedien kurz das
telekommunikation telemedien
datenschutzgesetz dsg kurz vor das ist
kurz kommentare ja und da steht in
absatz 2 kann hier mal sagen anbieter
von telemedien haben die nutzung
anonym und unter pseudonym zu
ermöglichen soweit dies technisch
möglich und zumutbar ist das heißt diese
disco brands spielt
weiterhin übrigens auch offensichtlich
sehr bewusst weil der gesetzgeber jetzt
ja hier noch etwas neues wieder
geschaffen hat ich finde das auch eine
interessante konstellation
und das ganze hat nach seiner auflösung
also irgendwann wird sich der bgh
tatsächlich dazu äußern müssen was denn
jetzt nun einfach hier gelten soll
sophia und jetzt kommen wir zu dem
gerechten urteil oder vielmehr zu den
schönen anekdoten aus dem gerichtssaal
im weitesten sinne bitte liegt muss im
aller weitesten sinne denn es ist in
dieser woche eigentlich weder gerecht
noch ein urteil es ist einfach nur schön
es ist wie es auf linkedin angekündigt
wurde eine weltpremiere
also es ging tatsächlich darum
würde sagen im weitesten sinn um die
digitalisierung der justiz oder
vielleicht in diesem fall eher der
anwaltschaft ein kölner partner einer
deutschen großkanzleien ich habe ihn
gefragt und ich darf ihnen namentlich
nennen dr ruben hofmann hat in der
vergangenen woche unglaublich viele
likes bekommen für einen link in post wo
er ab wo sich selbst abgebildet haben
also schönes helfe mit einer maske und
in robe und jetzt hat der blitz aus dem
zug guten ruf mann war nämlich unterwegs
auf dem weg nach hamburg und wollte da
vertreten in einer marken und
wettbewerbsrechts sache vor gericht und
er dachte sich obwohl die video
verhandlung möglich gemacht hatten ich
fahre mal lieber hin weiter ist halt so
so irgendwie marken und wettbewerbsrecht
da kann man auch gerne mal was zeigen
geht man gerne mal zum richterinnen
tisch nach vorne hatte er sich so
vorgestellt kam nicht so 50 kilometer
von hamburg stand der zug schwerer
defekt nix gemerkt was macht ruben
hofmann er wird sich im bahnabteil die
robe über und wählt sich in die video
konferenz ein wie gesagt es gab ohnehin
eine video-konferenz der gegnerische
anwalt war auch natürlich auch sehr
kanzlei zugeschaltet und der rogen
hofmann hat dann an der mündlichen
verhandlung in hamburg aus dem zug
teilgenommen jetzt könnte man denken
irgendwie niedliche geschichte das hat
er aber wir sind ja schließlich alle
juristinnen und juristen nicht einfach
so gepostet sondern schön mit folgenden
heute rungen gerichtsverhandlungen per
video konferenz sind möglich 128a zb die
norm gibt nicht vor wo man dabei seien
mehr als anwalt einzige vorgabe ist
wohin man muss sich im inland aufhalten
war der fall war es vor hamburg ist im
inland aber könnte man eigentlich auch
schon überlegen ob das notwendig sein
muss aber gut wenn es erstmal so ist
dann wollen wir das nicht auch noch
problematisieren genau dann hat er sich
noch überlegt was wenn ich hier soll ja
mal vorkommen hört man in der deutschen
bahn aus dem internet fliehen und hat
eine kölner kollegen bescheid gegeben
der sich dann noch zeitgleich aus dem
büro ein gewählt hat um die
ordnungsgemäße vertretung der mandantin
jederzeit zu sichern dann hat er sich
auch noch gefragt verletzt sich dann
nicht irgendwelche vertraulichkeit
pflichten wenn ich hier mitten im
bahnabteil sie zu mir alle zuhören
können nein tun dann natürlich nicht wir
auch selbst zurecht schrieb
gerichtsverhandlungen sind schließlich
öffentlich die verhandlung ist
offensichtlich gut gelaufen und im
protokoll der mündlichen verhandlung
wird jetzt stehen für die klägerin dr
hofmann aus dem zug fährt muss sagen ich
habe mich sehr über diesen preis gefreut
normale menschen würden halt irgendwie
schreiben hey heute aus dem zug an einer
gerichtsverhandlung teilgenommen
juristinnen und juristen schreiben einen
riesen post mit fünf rechtfertigung und
haben einmal im kopf alles komplett
durch geprüft nun gab aber ein riesen
hallo natürlich auch viele total lustig
juristen kommentare so in der richtung
von wegen fahrender gerichtsstand stadt
fliegender gerichtsstand und sonne aber
nicht für die jura babbel war begeistert
das war ein riesen hype auf linkedin hat
der post jetzt stand heute über 7.500
likes nur 350 kommentares über 700.000
mal gesehen worden mittlerweile sogar
ins französische übersetzt worden geht
auch nach frankreich total steil die
marketingchefin der deutschen bahn hat
sich persönlich zu wort gemacht wird und
sich bedankt und sich sehr gefreut
darüber und für ein interview antenne
niedersachsen hat auch schon sie ist
sollte man kann auch mal sagen wie
stabil die
internetverbindung im zug ist aber gut
nun stand der auch ne also ja das habe
ich auch der grund dafür dass es mal so
positive publicity gab und zieht die
marketingchefin der deutschen bahn so
gefreut
200 bei 250 km h ist das vielleicht
nicht ganz so leicht eine stabile
internetverbindung sicherzustellen aber
wirklich sehr und da kann man sehen
juristen schmunzeln gern einmal wenn es
passt wenn es etwas zu schmunzeln gibt
um es mit loriot her sagt genau gut so
und dann sind wir jetzt aber auch am
ende dieser folge dieses podcast es
angelangt wir danken für die
aufmerksamkeit freuen uns über feedback
bei einspruch podcast faz.de oder auch
im internet punkt
[Musik]
bleibt uns gewogen habt eine gute woche
da draußen
[Musik]